but first up he is the founder of the
Rainbow PUSH coalition when Charlotte's
Ville happened I was watching on TV I
said you know who I want to talk about
this I want to get him on Jesse Jackson
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're not gonna do a stage dive oh yeah
I may die all right so listen um you
you're nervous why you've never done
this it's been a while
big news thank you but listen I meant
what I said I was watching that that
Saturday and I was like you know how I
got here on this is you you worked
alongside of course Martin Luther King
you were there at the moment of the
assassination and this seemed like I'm
in his quote it's the letter from the
Birmingham jail I'm sure you know it
better than all of us he he once said
and I thought it was apropos to this
situation he said I have almost reached
the regretable conclusion that the
Negroes great stumbling block is not the
Ku Klux Klan er but the white moderate
who was more devoted to order than to
justice the context those who
hypocritically are embarrassed by
behavior that's that's ugly we vote
another direction for example there are
those who decried Trump's statement
about an on statement about
Charlottesville right but they also
voted for Jefferson Boulevard sessions
to be Attorney General the Jefferson
Beauregard said right the attorney named
after Jefferson Davis and the general
the Confederate Jews right bro regard
yeah those who are against Trump's
statements but then votes would shift
health care money from the poor the
wealth care for the rich right the the
moderate the nice guys they don't like
to be there they're embarrassed but
they're not change agents and other
things that we need change it it's not
just people who embarrassed because
that's personal you know
[Applause]
we saw these people marching and they
were you know they were not wearing the
hoods they were carrying the tiki
torches and the sometimes Nazi flags
shouting horrible things but we saw
their faces and in this day and age you
can match those faces we could look
these people up and probably get them
fired at their jobs is that a wise thing
well they feel emboldened they feel they
have protection from them from the White
House right and that is a lot of lot of
strength today I'll pay oh the sheriff
of Arizona was pardoned in spite of a
night yeah record on immigration in
spite of his racial profiling and so he
they feel protected by the President and
so when you put more focus on being a
fan of David Duke than he'll hire that
says something about the climate in the
country that's poisonous and we deserve
we deserve much better
[Applause]
I read a poll that said 40 percent 5% of
Trump fans his voters think that whites
are more discriminated against they they
are the most discriminated against and
Christians are the religion that's most
discriminated against 54% said that you
got to have a special kind of chip on
your shoulder as a white Christian to
think you're the one who got dealt a bad
hand that maybe something else going on
really
70% of Americans 78% live paycheck to
paycheck
51% makes $30,000 a year or less there's
a deep sense of anxiety where you've had
we've globalized the economy without in
a sense of care for these persons they
feel locked out and they feel and they
start skateboarding well my problem is
the Muslims are coming my problem is
Jews come up and so they are they are
being exploited but there's tremendous
economic anxiety that must not be
ignored
okay let me ask you about some other
issues that are in the news colin
kaepernick
I want to know what you think about that
because first of all I predict he's
gonna get picked up by a team it's
becoming too big he's actually not a bad
player and the fact that Matt is he
should have the right to express himself
he's not burning a flag
[Applause]
he's not shooting people with guns
Jackie Robinson once said that he would
not salute the flag not sing the
national anthem
because he felt it was not protecting
him best timer Smith and John Carlos at
the Olympics showing their fists right
that's all he said I will not go to the
war because Muhammad Ali right did not
go know and so there's a lineage of
athletes who've taken their stands that
is real athletes get all of this super
money today because crits lord siva not
be sold he didn't write to sell them so
all the free agents that comes from a
guy who stood up so maybe the hypnic is
that one guy who stands up he should not
the owners have colluded
they've decided in London and they
dimply and he should have the right to
play and express himself at the same
time and it just seems so mean-spirited
I mean considering how black people have
been treated in this country the whole
stadium should get on their knee silence
sounds of the Players Association is the
kind of betrayal they are too silent in
light of what they face they always face
zombie [ __ ] that affects them personally
but never quite as noble as the issue of
Kaepernick he's saying that blacks are
shot down and they've lied about to the
until the cameras exposed it said it's
not right when you look at the case of
Trayvon Martin killed and the killer
walks free look at the case in Ferguson
Missouri and the killer walks free
somebody says black lives matter he says
it's not right we deserve you could
protection under the law we should honor
keeping it but it's my last question to
you I agree with that but Steve Bannon
who just left the White House his his
exiting statement was I hope the
Democrats keep pursuing identity
politics race is a loser for them they
play that card and we're gonna kill them
in the next election what do you say to
that well the Democrats played identity
politics too much know we live in a
multiracial multicultural society
Hillary won by three million votes Trump
lost bathroom again votes when when the
when the Republicans want to embrace the
status' of competitors who engaged in
secession and slavery and segregation
and Sedition decid into politics when
they have no regard for the rights of
immigrants they will build a wall
between us and our next-door neighbor
Mexico they suggest that and that a
federal judge was Mexican cannot
dispense justice there senator politics
and so we fight the gender politics and
race politics we fight but multi Russian
multiracial multicultural society and
it's the right thing to do thank you for
coming here
[Applause]
let's meet our panel